I thank you guys and sorry for not being
Indian it is good to be here though I
don't know if you the server has ever
happened to you guys I got home from
work yesterday and a locksmith had left
his business card outside my door to
advertise his locksmith service all I
could think is this would make a much
better ad if I'd found it inside on my
pillow I like living in LA but I run
into a lot of tourists out here like
whenever I'm in Hollywood I see a lot of
Chinese tourists and it's weird as the
swine flu scare has been over for years
but they still walk around wearing those
swine flu masks which is a scary sight
for a guy who grew up playing Mortal
Kombat but I really do see people from
all over the world out here like I was
at Universal Studios and I saw tourists
who look like he was from Africa
admiring that giant fountain they have
out front and I thought how would you
even explain a giant fountain to someone
visiting from Africa like no sir you
don't put your mouth in there see here
in America we have so much clean
drinkable water that sometimes we just
use the extra to decorate
and then what we do is we take our spare
change which is the extra money we have
left over after buying everything we
could possibly want we just throw it in
the fountain and make a wish for a
better life if there's ducks in the
fountain we'll throw in the bread we
have leftover after eating everything we
could possibly eat we basically take our
leftover food and our leftover money and
throw it in our leftover water have fun
back in Africa but we care way too much
about food in this country I read a
study that said Americans nowadays get
more excited about food than they do
about sex which sounds crazy but that is
reflected in the metaphors we use what
do you think about it you know kissing
his first-base fooling around his second
and third base and having sex as a home
run but to eggs bacon hashbrowns and
pancakes as a Grand Slam
we have eating too much I'd dinner the
other night at Applebee's I don't know
how many you guys have eaten at
Applebee's lately they have basically
gotten to the point where they're just
naming their food after the type of
diarrhea it causes I guess I will start
with the sliders and the poppers and I
will have the mudslide and finally the
chocolate meltdown no no no make it the
fudge shooter which I promise you are
all real Applebee's items wha I was
hanging out with a friend and I
suggested going to Applebee's and she
goes no let's go to the rainforest cafe
I was like the rainforest cafe is like
someone played Jumanji in an Applebee's
[Laughter]
[Applause]
we eat so much in this country that
there's an obesity epidemic and that
obesity epidemic got so bad that there
was a reality show called I didn't know
I was pregnant that's true if you
haven't seen it it's this series about
these girls who are so overweight that
they don't even realize they're gonna
have a baby
until one day they're in the bathroom
and they go number three which is a baby
I'm 30 now so I'm at that age where a
lot of my friends are having babies like
one of my friends just had her third
child and she wants a new car but she
can't decide between a van or a minivan
I was like you definitely want a minivan
because a minivan is great if you're the
type of person who has to go around and
pick up your kids a lot a van is great
if you're the type of person who goes
around and picks up other people's kids
I actually came up with an idea for a
reality show that would help solve the
problem of child abduction and also the
problem of illegal immigration see how
it would work is each week we'd have an
illegal immigrant and a child molester
just fight each other and we call it
alien versus Predator
well not somebody came up to me after
showing called me a bigot for joking
about illegal immigrants because
apparently you're not supposed to use
that term anymore
but I think really it's the term bigot
that gets thrown around too much these
days like there's even this stereotype
that NASCAR fans are already necks and
bigots which I don't really think is
fair because I don't think NASCAR fans
can help it
I don't I mean people who are into the
cello are cellists and people who earn
to gymnastics are gymnasts so naturally
people are into racing
our racists if anyone's still working on
it if you're still working on the
locksmith joke it's like Easy's
locksmith tools to open the door and
leave
[Applause]
funny I mean user that start selling it